nous sommes le vendredi 19 septembre
nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction de TVfil 78 le point sur
l'actualité du jour et comme chaque fin
de semaine l'essentiel de ce qu'il faut
retenir découvrir le Centre des
monuments nationaux du Panthéon à la
basilique cathédrale de Saint-Denis au
fabuli c'est un jeu vidéo en ligne qui
vous permettra de découvrir la richesse
du patrimoine français le développement
a été porté notamment par l'université
de Versailles SaintQuentin invité du
journal edvig Le Lièvre chef du projet
Jérôme Gedge nouveau président de
l'office HLM au Pivois fait sa rentrée
il n'hésite pas à attaquer pour manque
d'implication au sein du conseil
d'administration les conseils généraux
du valdoise et des Yvelines l' Pivois
premier bailleur social public en région
parisienne avec un parc de 50000
logements de la forte mobilisation des
notaires contre la déréglementation de
leur profession à la semaine de la
mobilité en passant aussi par les 60 ans
du début des événements en Algérie nous
reviendrons aussi sur les principales
informations développées sur notre
antenne depuis lundi la ville de laav
verrière organise ce soir un conseil
municipal extraordinaire et une réunion
publique pour exposer la situation à ses
habitants une partie de la commune ne
répond en effet plus au critères de
l'État pour prétendre au classement en
zone géographique prioritaire un
classement qui permet d'obtenir des
subventions le maire a par ailleurs
interpellé le Gouvernement sur ce sujet
la séance de ce conseil extraordinaire
débutera à 19h ce vendredi soir à
l'Hôtel de Ville politique toujours et
nous restons sur ce secteur de la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines avec son
député Jean-Philippe my il est en ligne
avec nous bonjour à vous oui bonjour
bonjour Jean-Philippe my dans une
dizaine de jours vous allez céder votre
place à l'Assemblée à Benoît Hamont
puisque vous êtes son suppléant et qu'il
a à présent quittter le gouvernement
mais en tout cas c'est vous qui avez dû
prendre part au vote de confiance ou non
au nouveau gouvernement Vals deuxiè
gouvernement de ce de ce quinkena pour
Manuel Vals qu'avez-vous voté avez-vous
voté ou non la confiance vous qui avez
toujours été plutôt critique envers les
actions de de François
Hollande j'ai j'ai voté la confiance
j'ai voté la confiance comme je l'avais
je l'avais fait pour pour le
gouvernement Vals 1 j'ai toujours alors
que j'ai été député pendant 2 ans dans
la mesure où Benoît Hamont avait été
appelé au gouvernement j'ai toujours à
la fois voté les textes budgétaires et
voté la confiance donc j'ai toujours
inscrit mon action dans la loyauté au
gouvernement et à l'action de François
Hollande mais je n'ai jamais hésité à à
lorsqu'il y avait des projets de loi qui
nous étaient proposés à dire maises des
accords mes
proposition ça me semble être le minimum
pour un député c'est le travail du
député que de que d'amender mais vous
vous ne considérez pas aujourd'hui vous
ne considérez pas que vous êtes un un
frondeur vous ne diriez pas ça vous
n'êtes pas un frondeur au sein du Parti
socialiste moi je n'aime pas je n'aime
pas tellement le terme de frond vous
voyez il y a un économiste de très haut
vol qui s'a qui s'appelle s'appelle al
muet c'est un grand économiste qui a été
le président de l'Association française
des professeurs de sciences économies
bon qui est député socialiste bien il a
régulièrement dans des articles dans des
articles et des revues spécialisées en
en économie indiqué pourquoi cette
politique uniquement de de
l'offre
était n'était pas très bonne quoi avait
des avait des effets pervers bien il a
donc eu un regard critique sur ce que
l'on appelle cette politique de l'ofre
et bien il a voté la confiance hein il a
aussi voté la la confiance vous avez un
certain nombre de députés qui on qui
n'ont jamais hésité à dire les choses au
gouvernement mais mais qui sont aussi
dryau et qui ne veulent pas rajouter une
crise institutionnelle ou politique à à
une difficulté à une situation pardon un
contexte un climat déjà bien lourd mais
ceci dit la majorité à l'Assemblée est
plutôt courte hein pour pour Manuel Vals
269 voix pour contre 306 en avril
dernier lors du premier vote au à son à
son premier gouvernement c'est suffisant
pour gouverner sereinement
oui bien sûr alors vous me direz que
c'est une une majorité relative hein
mais moi je je suis je suis convaincu
que de toute façon le
gouvernement le président de la
République l'exécutif
trouveront toujours une majorité de de
députés socialistes pour pour voter les
et les texte budgétaire ce qui est
essentiel euh et et la confiance quoi
hein donc il y a à la fois cette cette
grande responsabilité vraiment euh des
députés socialistes mais qui n'hésitent
jamais à à dire des choses sur des sur
des projets de loi hein sinon à quoi bon
avoir avoir 577 députés euh si c'est
pour avoir des députés uniquement
auillot on pourrait trè ceci dit la
conférence de presse hier la conférence
de presse hier de François Hollande son
discours ça vous a rassuré par rapport à
vos positions vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir été entendu on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il y a non plus de
d'inflexion prévue dans la politique du
gouvernement
oui tout à fait pardon de toute façon
effectivement le président de la
République qui a d'ailleurs été très
très digne honnêtement qui a vraiment me
semble-t-il fait fait une prestation de
de qualité empreinte de de gravité a
clairement réaffirmé son
capadre son orientation l'orientation de
sa politique économique bien
écoutez moi j'en prends acte on peut on
peut et on le dit en interne en des
accords mais ça une fois de plus ça ne
m'a pas empêché à quelques jours
d'ailleurs de mon départ du Palais
Bourbon de voter la confiance merci
Jean-Philippe my d'avoir été en ligne
avec nous vous siégez encore à
l'Assemblée vous le disiez pour quelques
jours avant le retour de Benoît amont
sur les bancs de l'Assemblée merci à
vous merci l'opivois plus important
bailleur social public de la région un
nouveau président après le départ de
Romain Colas devenu député c'est Jérôme
Gedge qui est à la tête de l'instance et
pour sa rentrée il il n'hésite pas à
tacler les élus des conseils généraux
des ivelines et du valdoise qui malgré
leur obligation ne siègent plus au sein
du conseil d'administration de l'opivois
donc il évoque dérives de gestion et
situation catastrophique Catrine
zulato Jérôme Gedge a démarré sa
conférence de presse avec une demiure de
retard la raison un conseil
d'administration qui a duré plus
longtemps que prévu mais une fois assis
le nouveau président de l'opivoie va
vite et ne mâche pas ses mots il attaque
bille en tête ses partenaires du
valdoise et des ivelines qui selon lui
font la la chaise vide oui moi j'ai été
frappé et heurté de voir des élus du
Conseil Général du 78 et du Conseil
Général du valdoise qui depuis 2 ans
refuse de siéger au conseil
d'administration de l'opivois ils y ont
leur place mais depuis 2 ans ils n'ont
pas désigné leur représentant ça à teste
d'une forme de désinvolture une
désinvolture comme dit Jérôme GED qui
peut peut-être s'expliqué par la
situation financière de l'Office 1
milliard d'euros de dette oui
l'endettement a progressé à l'opivoie
mais précisément parce que nous avons
construit plus de logements avec ce
chiffre exceptionnel de 1143 logements
en en 2000 en 2013 mais l'endettement
est soutenable financé par les loyers et
les annuitités de remboursement que nous
avons sont en dessous de la moyenne
nationale pour le même ratio des offices
HLM des élus des ivelines et du valdoise
ont d'ailleurs dénoncé des déri de
gestion Jérôme Gedge fait toutefois fil
de ses critiques pour annoncer un
chiffre 600 c'est le nom nombre de
logements qui seront construits en 2014
et 2015 pour rappel en 2008 l'Office
avait livré 28 logements et 1147 en 2013
l'opivois ce sont 50000 logements en
Île-de-France dont 16000 dans les
ivelines l'invité du journal à présent
de ce 19 septembre ETV le lièvre
bienvenue bonjour maître de conférence à
l'Université de versaill 550 an en
Yveline rattaché au Centre d'histoire
culturel des sociétés contemporaines
vous travaillez à la valorisation
patrimoniale à travers le jeu et la
création numérique on va donc parler de
jeux vidéo avec vous le projet qui vient
de se terminer c'est ostia fabulis au
fabulis pour la les les initiés c'est un
jeu vidéo mais pas uniquement est-ce que
vous pouvez nous nous représenter un
petit peu ce concept ce projet alors
c'est un jeu vidéo et c'est aussi un
projet de recherche donc c'est un jeu
vraiment expérimental on peut dire aussi
indépendant puisqu'on n pas d'éditeur et
il est gratuit il est accessible au
public ben du coup en version finale
depuis hier c'est un jeu dans lequel les
joueurs sont amenés à explorer les
monuments du Centre des monuments
nationaux il y en a 19 ça fait s lieu
donc c'est vraiment très grand et il y a
une histoire qui est une fiction qui
amène justement à découvrir ces
monuments il y a plusieurs fins
plusieurs possibilités dans cette
histoire et disons que c'est quelque
chose qui est à l'hybri un hybride on va
dire entre les point and click donc les
jeux d'aventure les jeux d'énigme et les
MMO RPG les jeux en ligne multijoueurs
multiutilisateurs ceux qui veulent le
télécharger il faut ensuite être
connecté pour jouer en permanence et
pouvoir échanger parce que c'est là le
principe être en en communi comunication
avec les autres joueurs tout à fait
alors il est déjà téléchargeable donc
gratuitement sur
ofabulis.fr vous pouvez jouer sur Mac et
sur PC bientôt aussi sur tablette
effectivement il faut une connexion
internet ça par contre on ne peut rien
faire sans puisque le jeu est
multijoueur persistant et donc il
favorise le jeu en groupe vous disz
c'est un projet de recherche quel est
l'objet de cette recherche alors il y en
a plusieurs une des une des objectif
c'est évidemment de vérifier que le jeu
vidéo en ligne peut être un outil
intéressant pour la valorisation du
patrimoine un autre objet c'est
d'étudier le fonctionnement des
communautés virtuelles ensuite je
cherche aussi à voir si ce type d'espace
qu'on a créé avec un mélange de photos
et de personnages en 3D est efficace
pour l'immersion par exemple et
peut-être après on va voir dans les
monuments si ça a un impact sur la
visite à la fois sur le nombre de
visitees et sur la façon dont les gens
visitent les monuments ça peut permettre
aux gens de venir découvrir pantéon
château de Vincen château de maison la
fit tout ça ce sont des lieux qui sont
représentés et qui sont modélisés
exactement au pixel PRS au détail près
alors effectivement on a donc 19 ne9f
monuments en île-france et dans les
ivelines on a le château de maison
maison la fite et la ville à Savoie mais
on a aussi toute la France puisqu'on a
le montsmichel bien sûr le château d'If
le château d'azel rideau la forteresse
de Mont Dauphin alors ils ont été faits
à partir de photos qui sont donc des des
travaux exactement enfin très précis on
a on les a réalisé avec des spécialistes
et à partir de ça on les a recréé en 3D
mais de manière assez simplifiée pour le
coup ce qui permet que ce soit
suffisamment fluide et d'accueillir
jusqu'à 30 Jin en simultanée à l'écran
le développement du jeu vous a pris
combien de temps alors on a commencé
mi-février on a livré une première
version en betta test pour futur en
scène en juin et donc aujourd'hui nous
sommes en septembre je faire le CAL fait
assez rapidement finalement tout à fait
ça a été assez rapide ça reste un projet
expérimental on ne peut pas comparer
avec des des projets à 20 million
d'euros bien sûr mais oui ça s'est fait
assez vite les retours que vous avez
pour l'instant le téléchargement du jeu
alors que les joueurs à quel public vous
visez aussi peut- alors on vise les 18
30 ans ça c'est ce qu'on vise et on
commence à avoir effectivement des
premiers tours alors les joueurs adèent
mais c'est c'est assez varié et
finalement on n pas que des 18 30 ans on
a pu voir assez récemment qu'il y a
aussi des familles qui s'y mettent on a
vu des ados de 15 ans adorer le jeu il
s'y sont mis mais il s'est trouvé ça un
peu dur parce que le jeu est conçu pour
des adultes du coup ils ont engrainé
leurs parents leurs petits frères et ça
fait qu'il y a aussi des familles qui
jouent aujourd'hui pour faire découvrir
le patrimoine justement il faut mélanger
art numérique jeux vidéo science de
l'information de la communication c'est
une piste c'est une piste notamment pour
effectivement les 18 30 ans qui n vont
pas puisque les gens ils vont quand ils
sont contrat et forcés quand ils sont
enfants par les enseignants par les
parents après ils arrêtent et ils y
retournent quand à nouveau ils ont des
enfants et qu' les emmènent et du coup
cette cible là qui pour le coup
s'intéresse beaucoup au numérique et au
jeux vidéo mais pas trop au monuments ça
peut être une bonne méthode en tout cas
c'est c'est ce qu'on essaie de voir ici
ensuite de les emmener directement de
les amener à visiter ces lieux il y a
une implication des monuments historiqu
sur sur ce sur ce jeu justement pour
ensuite se dire bah ça peut permettre de
faire venir des gens de venir vous voir
ah oui énormément en fait on était trois
partenaires sur le projet donc
l'université de versailles-
Saint-Quentin le Centre des monuments
nationaux et émissive une PME qui a fait
une grosse partie du développement et
donc le Centre des monuments nationaux
nous ont déjà permis de tourner dans ces
lieux magiques les agents du centre ont
pour certains accepté d'être filmés donc
ils font partie du jeu on peut les
retrouver dans des vidéos interactives
et et puis aussi ils m'ont beaucoup aidé
à écrire le scénario ils m'ont fourni
énormément d'histoire de légendes que
vous trouverez jamais sur internet que
jamais dans des livres même pour
certaines et à partir de ça j'ai j'ai
écris un scénario qu'ils ont vérifié
pareil pour les quêtes et les énigmes de
façon à ce que ce soit même si c'est une
fiction la trame principale très sérieux
en ça reste cohérent même si tout n'est
pas historiquement véridique dans le jeu
si tout est historiquement véridique et
il y a aussi des vraies légendes
d'accord si je me permet des vrais
légendes ça a coûté cher à développer il
y a eu un vrai investissement financier
aussi parce que le but ça va pas être de
le rentabiliser tout ça est gratuit pour
le téléchargement pour les joueurs alors
ça peut être rentabilisé par les entrées
dans les monuments quand même mais c'est
pas un énorme budget pour un jeu vidéo
de ce typel c'est vraiment très petit
puisque le jeu a coûté 90000 €. donc
30000 € du Centre des monuments
nationaux 60000 € de la région
île-de-fance à titre comparatif un jeu
vidéo du même registre mais développé
par une société privée c'est 20 millions
c'est 20 millions et vous arrivez à à
faire avec toutes les contraintes alors
évidemment on n arrive pas tout à fait
au même niveau de finition qu'un jou à
20 millions ça c'est c'est pas possible
et notamment on a dû trouver des petites
astuces et notamment les décors qui sont
faits à partir de photos évidemment s'il
avait fallu refaire le mont sa-michel en
3D c'était plus cher çaé aussi beaucoup
plus long et mobiliser encore plus
d'acteurs de de ce projet de de
recherche le jeu est téléchargeable si
vous voulez aller l'essayer dès à
présent vous allez continuer votre
travail puisque vous allez regarder
comment il va évoluer comment il va
vivre à présent ce jeu puisque on le
rappelle c'est en ligne et la communauté
est appelée à grandir et à échanger
entre elles tout à fait donc il va y
avoir moi je suis chercheur en
information et communication donc il va
y avoir toute une étude utilisateur à la
fois avec les données du jeu à partir de
sondage qu'on va proposer aux joueurs
des questionnaires un peu plus précis et
mais on va aussi continuer de faire
évoluer le jeu par rapport à ses retours
et parce que SII les jeux en ligne
fonctionnent comme ça en fait même les
jeux professionnels à 20 millions
d'euros vous allez avoir des patchs très
régulier et on va garder ce modèle là on
va essayer d'améliorer le jeu tout tout
au long de l'année donc des mises à jour
assez régulières pour dès qu'il y a un
retour qui sera fait par les
utilisateurs au fabulis disponible dès à
présent c'est une bonne idée pour
découvrir le patrimoine ce sont les
journées du patrimoine ce weekend si
vous n'avez pas l'occasion de sortir de
chez vous pourz en tout cas essayer le
le jeu merci d'être venu nous parler de
ce projet qui est aujourd'hui disponible
en téléchargement sur Internet merci à
merci
beaucoup nous revenons à présent sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
comme chaque vendredi après les
huissiers et lundi ce sont les notaires
mercredi qui se sont mobilisés avec le
même engouement grève manifestation à
Paris pour une profession pourtant un
peu habitué à se faire entendre c'est le
projet de loi d'ouverture à la
concurrence qui les inquiète exemple
auprès d'une étude basée à Guill encours
avec Catherine
zulato nous sommes à Guill encour dans
cette étude de depuis quelques jours le
ton est donné les affiches sont sans
ambiguïté les notaires ne veulent pas de
l'ouverture à la concurrence souhaitée
par le gouvernement dans un objectif de
réduction des coûts notariaux une
ouverture totale elle serait
préjudiciable à tous les Français ça
c'est très important elle serait
vraiment préjudiciable à la population
puisque les pays qui ont fait
l'ouverture comme elle est souhaitée au
jour d'aujourd'hui en
France payent plus cher et ont une
meilleure une moins bonne protection
aujourd'hui notre profession elle est
très encadrée elle s'ex porte à
l'étranger puisque notre modèle est
suivi notamment en Chine en Mongolie en
Serbie
elle le modèle de droit que que nous
avons et s'exporte très bien et on voit
pas pourquoi il faudrait le modifier
aujourd'hui et la Chambre des notaires
d'appuyer son argumentaire d'un chiffre
en France un dossier sur 1100 fait
l'objet d'un sinistre alors que dans les
pays de droit anglo-saxon ouvert à la
concurrence il y aurait un sinistre pour
trois dossiers les ivelines compent 65
études notariales selon la Chambre
Professionnelle ce mercredi 100 % des
études du département avaient fermé
leurs portes à l'image des autres études
françaises une toute première fois pour
cette profession qui remplit une mission
de service
public la guerre d'Algérie un conflit
débuté voici 60 ans 5 novembre 1954 le
gouvernement français envoie des renfort
militaire après le déclenchement d'une
rébellion armée une guerre
d'indépendance et de décolonisation
doublé d' guerre civile avant les
accords d' viiant du 18 mars 62 des
appelés de France partent sur place il
découvrent l'horreur du conflit mais
aussi la torture la ville de Manil et
Amot est très impliquée dans le devoir
de mémoire et elle a commandé récemment
auprès de l'auteur anne- Sophie chilard
un ouvrage de témoignage 21 habitants de
la commune tout sappelé d'Algérie
reviennent sur ces moments qui ont
changé leur vie Anne-Sophie chilard qui
était en plateau cette semaine voici
quelques extraits de son
intervention certains acteurs on ont
refusé quand le le projet a été proposé
par la mairie de de témoigner ceux qui
ont accepté de témoigner l'ont fait
vraiment avec une grande sincérité que
je tiens à souligner ici mais c'était
toujours douloureux et compliqué
certains parlaient pour la première fois
la plupart en fait m'ont parlé pour la
première fois ce qui était très émouvant
pour moi parce que j'ai j'ai recueilli
des témoignage qui était vraiment vierge
de toute parole et c'est la première
chose qui me disait en fait souvent la
première chose qu'il me disait c'est
qu'il n'avait rien de spécial à dire et
et ensuite la parole en fait était
vraiment très très importante et et
ensuite la deuxième chose c'est je n'en
ai jamais parlé à personne vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir fait un travail de
psychanalyse peut-être avec eux alors un
peu effectivement parce qu'en plus
le lie prêtaest toutes ces rencontres se
sont faites pour la plupart à la maison
des bonheurs à Manille et à mot
certaines chez les les personnes même et
souvent à la maison des bonheurs
effectivement j'avais un peu
l'impression quand on on fermait la
porte on était deux on était deux et et
au bout d'une heure 1 He3 parfois 2h
quand j'ouvrais la porte vraiment il y
avait un gros travail psychologique qui
s'était fait pour la personne qui
témoignait et pour moi
c'était recevoir une émotion très forte
parmi parmi les témoignages compilés
dans l'ouvrage gardealgérie 50 ans pour
défire mon pactage celui de Jean-Gérard
incorporé en juillet 1958 à il était en
CAB à Tamda près de tiouo nous sommes
aussi allés le rencontrer je suis
Monsieur Girard Jean j'ai 77 ans j'ai
été appelé en juillet
1958 j'ai reçu mon ordre de mission pour
partir en Algérie on a était vite mis à
la réalité une fois qu'on était Alger on
a pris la micheline pour nous rapatrier
à tiziouou et puis en cours de route on
s'est attaqué
donc distribution des armes et tout et
puis là ça peut-être partout on c'est
bien c'est plus de la Rigolette c'est
plus si joli que c'était on partait pas
encore vacances
oui c'est vrai je me suis
marié donc j'ai eu une permission
exceptionnelle et on s'est barié à ville
d'avraay en avril
1960 on était pr de se marier on était
et puis le coin était quand même beau je
voulais y faire un peu découvrir et lui
montrer la vie comment la vie était
là-bas c'est ça labas que je garde
surtout de de de formidable qu'il avait
c'est l'esprit de
camaraderie le matin les gradés on se
salevait pas on se serrait la main et
ceux qu'on parle pas souvent non plus
c'était le service
santé il y avait les chirurgiens les
médecins les infirmières ont fait un
travail remarquable et ça ça j'en a
toujours
garder un énorme souvenir ça a été c'est
pareil ça a été
une bonne expérience mais ça a été
certain fois très très très l
très mais nous plaignons pas on est
revenu il en a 30000 qui sont pas
revenus vous savez j'ai pas trop changé
la vie on est parti là-bas quand on voit
le résultat maintenant ça pas donné
grandchose qu'est-ce qu'on a ramené à
rien on a fait le travail de mémoire
depuis 11 ans ça fera 11 ans cette année
dans les école et vraiment les gamins
nous ont posé tout un tas de questions
et tout et on leur dit toujours à chaque
fois la paix ne vous battez pas dans la
cour de récréation ne vous bagarrez pas
parlez discutez expliquez-vous mais ne
faites pas la
guerre autre sujet au squir Gérard
Philippe àrape c'est l'agacement nous en
avons aussi parlé cette semaine les
habitants se disent excéder par leurs
conditions de vie stagnante odeur
noséabonde serait fréquente en début de
semaine un habitant a trouvé un rat elle
est locataire interpelle l'office HLM
qui dit ne pas avoir été averti de
l'ampleur du problème une intervention
est néanmoins en cours reportage en
intégralité sur le WW
tvfil78.com la semaine de la mobilité se
déroule en ce moment à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline avec ce samedi des animations
devant le Vélodrome à Montini le
broteneux et en parallèle de ce
rendez-vous une opération que vous avez
découvert mardi sur notre antenne une
opération baptisée 2 semaines sans ma
voiture vélo transport en commun à
chacun sa méthode plusieurs salariés du
secteur tentent de laisser leurs voiture
leur véhicules au garage cl
C c'est
parti la journée commence pour Céline
petit et ses enfants et pour se rendre à
l'école c'est trottinette ou vélo car la
jeune maman s'est lancé un défi de
semaines sans voiture un challenge
proposé par la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline pour célébrer la semaine de la
mobilité allez ciao
ciao première étape réussie même s'il a
fallu un peu s'adapter sur le trajet
ouais c'est vrai que le vélo quand il y
a un petit peu de monde bon ben il faut
faire attention il y a des enfants donc
il faut pas faut pas trop pédaler quoi
cet ingénieur informatique va maintenant
pousser jusqu'à Guille en cours pour
rejoindre son bureau elle a choisi de
passer par la base de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline un moyen de
profiter du paysage et d'éviter le
trafic et elle ne le regrette
pas ce matin j'ai mis 30 minutes et je
pense ça va aller le coup parce que j'ai
vu les bouffons sur la National 10 c'est
l'IT que je prend d'habitude et bon
c'est peut-être pas vrai tous les jours
mais ce matin ça valait vraiment le coup
en plus il faisit beau je pense que
j'aurais mis bien 40 minutes en voiture
son mode de transport alternatif le vélo
électrique est proposé à la location par
sa société le Crédit Agricole SA mais
pour cette semaine de défi c'est la
communauté d'agglomération qui finance à
Mani lesamo nous retrouvons un autre
volontaire Jean-Pierre Schweitzer est
responsable du développement durable
chez ilti c'est donc tout naturellement
qu'il a accepté le défi c'est pas facile
de changer d'habitude donc le fait de
l'opportunité de ce défi me permet ben
de d'essayer quelque chose de
nouveau pour son premier jour il a
choisi le covoiturage mais durant ces
deux semaines il souhaite également
tester le transport en commun grâce à
l'application mobile WAZ up spécialisé
dans le covoiturage domicile travail il
a trouvé une personne qui fait le même
trajet que lui c'est
lui vassim salarié chez Renault inscrit
son passager via l'application
c'est bon là après quand quand quand on
arrive je le dépose voilà c'est vraiment
très simple comme Céline et Jean-Pierre
ils sont huit à tenter l'expérience
pendant de
semaines le journal se referme pour ce
vendredi et pour cette semaine toute
l'actualité locale est à suivre sur
internet sur notre site je vous retrouve
en tout cas lundi 18h pour une nouvelle
édition et dimanche dès 19h30 vous
découvrirez le premier numéro de café
politique nouveau rendez-vous bimensuel
sur TVfil euh pour mieux connaître le
parcours de vos élus mais aussi évoquer
avec eux les principaux dossiers qui les
occupent je recevrai pour cette première
Michel logier maire de Montini le
Bretonneux président de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline excellent
weekend